but example 5 looks like this so let me
draw a line and if you haven't done 5
you can go straight underneath this
what's being asked here ok so they say
you've got a continuous random variable
whose probability density function is
and they hand you that right so in this
case they're actually just telling you
this is the answer right you don't need
to check whether it is it's been it's
been checked for you as it were so I'm
just going to write up this is worked
example five f of X my probability
density function is given by 3x sweat
okay they give you also this interval so
you're like oh wait a second I have to
remember how to define regions not just
with my inner quality notation like this
but also with interval notation so it's
written as u @ly square brackets right 0
comma 1 how would you translate that by
the way you've got to be able to read
both but how would you write this with
inequalities from 0 is less than or
equal to X which is the scenario equal
to 1 is that okay so these are these are
equivalent okay so they're telling us
that it works on here what does the
question actually ask it says what is
the probability of this particular x
value being between 1/2 and what
inclusive inclusive right yeah so how am
I going to interpret this result right
here kind of a straight substitution
isn't it we've given you an f of X and
they've even supplied to you what the a
and the B are what's the a look every
it's 1/2 that's what we're particularly
interested in here and then when they
end all the way at 1 so I'm just going
to go straight from that definition and
I'm gonna say the probability of 1/2 is
less than or equal to X is less than or
equal 1 equals and then I write my my
integral ok from 1/2 to 1 of 3 x squared
that's what they gave us with respect to
X happy and then you're like okay I mean
I mean calculus mode now right so you
can tell me the primitive of 3x squared
it's going to be X cubed fantastic
evaluate that from 1/2 to 1 let's see
here so
one cute takeaway 1/2 cubed one take
away one over eight so this is 7/8 happy
with that which by the way should make
sense you don't need to do this but if
you have an image in your mind of what
this probability function looks like it
is helpful picked up the wrong color
what is 3 x squared looks like in the
domain that we've been asked for well it
looks very similar to what we're doing
just now it was part of a parabola it's
defined you remember from 0 to let's
call that 1 okay and you're like I'm
interested in the part from 1/2 which is
here all the way to 1 and you can see
even just by looking at my you know
hurried graph this is the area we were
calculating of course most of the
probability 7/8 of the probability is
over there because this is much more
likely ok one last thing we just
thinking really careful for I wanted to
pick out this example to notice it this
is my x-axis yeah right X and this is f
of X what is this value up here what's
it equal to have a think this function
is 3x squared remember have a think
being carefully if this is yeah yeah you
integrated right this is f of X which is
3x squared so the x value that goes with
the hotspot I picked was 1 so you put in
1 you get 3 times 1 squared this is 3
right now I just want to highlight it's
a little bit weird because we've been
thinking about those histograms there's
frequency histograms and when you do it
relative like the highest you can go is
1 right because all your probabilities
add up to that but these individual
values here like 3 that's not a
probability the area is the probability
ok so you might get weirded out by the
fact that your grass probability density
functions will look a bit different to
your arm histograms we've been doing in
discrete random variables ok